growing humans in bags and pots that's
coming that's coming yeah that's it
that's absolutely coming and and and
that's why a lot of Americans are are
left infertile and I think this is going
to be a bigger and bigger issue as we go
on mainly because sperm levels are are
going down the qualities of women's eggs
are going down people are not able to
have children I think a lot of this is
deliberate I think this is a Eugenics
operation that is being carried out on
the American people on the people of the
western world who are unsuspecting of
this larger chemical biological warfare
that is being waged on them but I think
the end game of all of this is to
essentially have pod babies is to to
have selective breeding is to have
Eugenics at the highest level where the
government says you now with your social
credit score have one permission to have
a child we're going to take your DNA
here we're going to grow a baby out of a
bag or even you know better off you know
what no no no we're just going to give
you a hunter Biden baby because that's
the baby that deserves to live on that's
the baby that of course actually is
going to get a life